si les mains sortie événement
aujourd'hui podium un film retraçant la
vie d'un sosie de que françois incarné
par benoît poelvoorde
on dit beaucoup de bien de ce film on
rit beaucoup on est touché par x 25 ans
après sa disparition il faut dire que
françois continue d'avoir du succès et
le faire l'objet d'un véritable culte
pascal deschamps diane richard voici
l'histoire mesdames et messieurs les
françoises ictoi de françois qu'on ait
jamais rang
pour bernard frédéric modeste employé de
vente marié un enfant
claude françois c'est plus qu'un hobby
c'est une seconde fut un vrai métier le
sens de sa vie un brin de folie parce
qu'un jour il l'a choisi parce que le
plan dit il c'est de l'émotion et des
reprises
c'était plutôt bram en mer avec brassens
toi hein le postage qui fait rêver
couillard et nouilles
j'ai peur le mode couillaud au fond du
ravin podium s'inspire bien sûr dans la
réalité de son vivant déjà toute force
leur plein effet des sosies vous dire
que dieu n'est arrivé au stade de france
à côté c'est rappeler - mulhouse mais
j'ai un lui même à l'époque il avait
organisé en songeant mal podium un
concours de sosies en 1974 et au vu des
résultats il avait reçu des centaines à
l'époque et des centaines de lettres
déjà de gens qui le clown est déjà à
l'époque il avait eu très très peur
finalement parce que c'est le c'est un
miroir qui est redoutable finalement les
sosies c'est un miroir qui vous renvoie
votre image d'une manière excessive
on repense
aujourd'hui le succès de confiance aux
mesures aux centaines de milliers
d'albums vendus chaque année
claude françois n'a jamais quitté ni les
bacs ni les coeurs lui qui se demandait
tous jeunes ce qu'on pouvait bien lui
trouver
je réfléchis souvent ça c'est un métier
quand même impressionnant pourquoi moi
et pas les en est on est on est 50
millions en france on a une chance
fabuleuse année quelques-uns pouvoir
avancer la chance de pouvoir
complètement genre d une chanson il
attendait que ça c'est une chose qui
nous à travers ces générations c'est je
pense que les parents inculque aux
enfants je crois que dans toutes les
soirées familiales dans toute la france
et c'est le co2 françois si vous voulez
c'est très populaire donc les gens sont
heureux c'est incroyable que 25 ans
après il existe il est là il est présent
et ccc je peux avoir qu'un excellent
souvenir de cela
autre baromètre le plus pur métriques
les visites au moulin du claude françois
a passé 14 ans de sa vie gay aujourd'hui
c'est un couple defrasne qui possède les
lieux reconverti en restaurant et en
musée alors ce drame il ya enfin les
plans de 200 à 1965
des cars entiers ce refus de vente une
mèche de cheveux un peignoir ou le
maillot de foot de l'équipe d'ismaïlia
en egypte offert par nasser 8 même
quelques milliers d'entrées à 9 euros
par an permettent aux propriétaires
d'entretenir les lieux et pour moi le
rêve d'adolescent qui se réalise
quand même et c'est vrai qu'on me dit
j'ai beaucoup de chance mais j'ai eu je
le redis tu préférerais que ce soit
claude qui sont ici vous sachiez les
filles quand les deux delpech l'allée
des sarno entraide moi de nous péter
comme des quoi claude b potron minet il
était ici et yogi podium ravira les
sosies les fans de cloclo ou de disco et
leurs enfants ou tous ceux qui ont envie
de rigoler et ça fait du monde